Hi, Rusin, how are you?
Actually, I'm good. Thanks, Sanya.
I'm good. How's everything going on your end?
Yeah, it's okay. It's okay. I know it's just going to be a few minutes later. We just jumped out of another meeting, but we'll be, we'll be a little shorter. Yeah, but how's things been on your side?
No worries, if you want, yeah, going good. If something there is urgent going on, I can definitely reschedule this meeting to next week as well. Okay, okay, good.
Oh no, no, it's okay. It's okay. It's important for us as well. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So...
How are the things over there?
Ohh, much better, Shashank, than the time we last chatted, which was chaos, you know, a lot of things have sort of happened, but we definitely sitting down a bit more at this stage, so yeah, definitely in a better space than when we last chatted, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
That's great to hear. So I guess there was an L2 that was starting or you promoted an L1 to L2 in your team. So how's that going now?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, so far it's been okay. The transition has worked good, you know, a lot of value coming in, so it's helping us, you know, with some of these binding items, but yeah, how's it gonna?
Oh.
Hey, how's it going?
Hey, hey, new hairstyle, I guess it's changed.
Good to see. Yeah, kind of.
It's looking good, looking good.
Thank you, thank you, man. Yeah.
Yeah.
With this new hairstyle, you look a lot younger, I would say.
Ohh, really?
Okay.
Yes, for sure.
All right, I'll take it as a compliment.
Yes.
So, right.
So, how are the things for you easing off a bit, like with the new new person stepping into as L2?
Oh yeah.
Oh yes, it is far better now. Thank you. And how's it going with you? How's everything? How's family? All okay?
Everything is okay, but you know the heat here is June and.
Mm.
Oh yeah, I get it, man.
I know, I get it. It's crazy. Yeah, yup, it is crazy.
You experienced this with her earlier.
Yeah, so definitely it's heat is very on the higher end. Summers are on its maximum, just waiting for July mid or July end where the monsoon kicks in and the things go better. But again, it would be humidity. Again, it would be a different challenge altogether.
Mhm.
Mm.
Oh yes, yes, it will be sweaty, right?
Yes, yeah, let's see how the things go.
Yeah.
That's great. Anything you want to discuss before I start with the presentation, or should I start?
Sure.
Uh, Rishan, we we should, right? Yeah, that's good.
I think, I think we're good, yeah, we're good, we're good.
Okay, so thanks for joining in. The agenda stays the same. So Nora has been performing well. She has been grasping and going in the right direction. So we did, I did speak up with her on ticket prioritization, workload management, and escalating it the right direction.
time and making correct communication. The problem that we talked about, the client updates and follow through on request, like she was not actively doing that. So I talked to her on that. Similarly, that's for onboarding as well. So SLA is also one major thing because we have a three day SLA for onboarding.
Mm.
Yeah.
And also what Roshin pointed out, like balancing the workload and while she's transitioning from an onboarding engineer to a systems analyst, that is there. So, Anil, I would first.
Hmm.
Mhm.
Ask you, do you see an improvement? Do you see better performance? Do you still see challenges?
To be honest, I see great performance improvement overall. I think she's doing good. I don't have much to add, but I'll certainly pass it on to Rishan. But from my side, I think she's doing okay. Nothing.
Major, yep.
Okay.
Rishi, over to you.
Yeah, thanks, Shashank. I think from our side as well, from my side, you know, there's been an improvement definitely, you know, on that proactiveness in terms of just managing the different tickets and, you know, reaching out quicker for help when she needs help. So, that's definitely been huge, even the client, you know, sort of feedback and making sure.
Mm.
the ticket is acknowledged and you know we giving that prompt feedback, there's been, you know, you could see a big difference between from the last time we chatted to to now. So I think that's been great. You know, also just to give us some, you know, quotas in terms of, you know, she's been proactively helping us.
Huh.
with some unique circumstances with licenses and things like that, where we're pushing a little bit out of her wheelhouse as well, right, to sort of make sure that she can go and do this research and be able to figure things out further and take it a step further instead of just, you know, depending on Anil or myself or someone else. So
She's been, you know, doing that proactively, and you know, we appreciate that, you know.
And just to let you know one thing, she had her promotion, ITBD internal promotion, so she got promoted. She cleared her written assessment and then a technical interview with one of the technical leads. So she got promoted. She got her written.
So...
later released. So that was one good information I wanted to share with you. That also happened side by side.
Yeah.
Oh, great, nice.
That's very good. Yeah, that's awesome. Thanks for that, Vishal.
Yeah.
And I think that gave her an extra confidence. Like now I moved to internal ITBD, I have moved to a senior position, so I need to be more responsible and let me give in more. I think that also kicked in a bit.
Mm.
Yeah.
Prince, that's excellent, yeah.
Yeah, which is great. Yeah, good to see, see that. Yeah, that's how we want to proceed, right? We want to recognize the right people, and then, of course, when you recognize them, you know, you see the great performance anyway, right? So, which is good, commendable, yeah.
Okay, moving on next for the ticket data, utilization is going good. It's about 90%, so that's good. Ticket closures have improved to one in 13 tickets. So I guess less of access and more of other tickets. So that's also.
Going good. CSAT is 100% over 14 service. This month, the number of service dipped a bit, but overall it's 100%, so that's good. Attendance, there was, that's going good. No unplanned leaves in the month of May.
June, they were, but yes, we'll cover that in the next month. Anything else which you would like to cover, Anilan? And honestly, I asked her if anything is pushing your health or anything, is there you're feeling extra pressure? She said no.
Mm.
She said that it's just general health issues that I have. And I'll be honest, last year she had a very bad health. So we gave her a lot of support and everything. And then she improved. I guess that was in.
August and September when she had a lot of health issues, but she had improved. She went to view the doctor regularly and now her health is good. It's just the general sometimes her health goes weak and that's why she has taken those leaves.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Okay. On that note, I have a question and rather a suggestion. Look, before I start, we do not promote the work from home culture, right? But in the cases where, you know, when an employee is unfit and we know that it can be a
greatest impact on the business, we, as an exception, we allow them that, hey, you can work from home for a day. And then probably once you get better, say tomorrow, you can come back and join the office. So do we have such kind of option? Because, you know, rather than taking sick leave, I prefer that she can just log in from home and then work.
Sure, and I'll let you know, like, in some cases we do allow, but with F12, this has been a mandate that has come from F12 from itself that do not allow work from home for any engineer.
Keith.
Hmm.
Okay.
That's an issue. But in general, in ITBD, we do not have work from home culture. Just in case there is some emergency or so, then we seek a leadership exception in that case and then give it. But in this case, it's denied by 12, so we do not do that.
Hmm.
Mm.
Okay.
But yes, we are mindful of the cases where we need to take care of that. And if it's a health issue, we generally ask the engineer to take leaves if it's very big and they cannot work. And we also, I'll tell you, there's one more engineer in my team, a female.
Yeah.
Okay.
She has some health issues. What we do, she comes and works from office only, but if in case her health goes wrong, we allow her to rest in the medical room and we inform the partner accordingly. So we do have this and in case she needs to leave early, we do provide an office cap for her to be dropped at home.
Yeah.
We are taking those precautions and measures in that case. We are very concerned about all the employees that we have in office.
Okay.
Mm.
All right, great. Thank you. Yeah.
Just saying from my side, it was just more just a concern, right? That she's doing okay because we chat to her and she says her health is okay. But if there's a serious underlying condition and she needs more support and stuff, then definitely let us know about that, you know, because, you know, we're just concerned from her point of view and her health and wellbeing and stuff. That's first priority always before work and anything else.
Sure.
Ohh.
But yeah, if there is something really more serious that she's dealing with, obviously she's starting to have to disclose it because that's personal health. But at least if we know that, you know, these certain weeks she is sort of facing more challenge than not, that's appreciated for us as well. So we can balance the workload and give the additional support that we need, right? But.
Sure.
Mm.
That visibility just needs to be there at one level without going into details of the help, because we have to respect everyone's privacy as well for that. We totally accept that. But it's just more so that we can support her and know these tough days that she could be having, and you know, be able to help in any way that we can, yeah, to alleviate some of that, yeah.
Yes.
Yeah.
So, Vishal, in this case, I'll call it out specifically. If the situation happens, then we'll first discuss with our internal leadership and then we'll take an exception from Lakhwinder because he manages that team and then he manages that aspect, so we'll take a...
exception approval from him in that case and then we'll let the employee work from home. But there are approvals that happens and we definitely would look into that aspect if the health goes so bad that the employee cannot work from office. So definitely we'll look into that aspect if the health goes.
Correct.
Very bad, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
deteriorates in that way. We are not inconsiderate, but we generally avoid.
Alright, yeah.
Totally, there has to be, there's rules as well, right? And it's also on our side as well. So it's, you know, otherwise, you know, there's always people that will take advantage of that in the wrong way. So, yes, exactly, exactly. So that's the reason why, but I'm just saying it from a personal level, Shashank, is that if she's having certain days where...
Mm.
We have seen, we have seen that.
you know, it's a bit hectic for us. She must just let Anil and I know. Just so that, you know, if the workload can be divided further, we'll support her on that, right? So it's less pressurized. If we need, if there's something urgent, we can reprioritize or move it to someone else. That helps us just to have a less pressurized day if a health is really impacting on that specific.
Mm-hmm.
Sure.
day, for example, right? But yeah, the days that she needs off, she must take it. You know, that's health and well-being comes first. So definitely it's not about, you know, she has to work because of that and stuff. We will, yeah, the team, yeah, yeah.
Hmm.
Shashank, I know one thing for sure. She carries such a great bond with Anil that she would first inform Anil and then inform me.
Yeah, yeah.
Totally, yeah.
Yeah, I know.
Excuse me.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, because...
She's, she's a, she's a good beta.
And Vishal, I'll tell you one thing. There was one time when our office internet was, we were facing issues because the ISP was going down and because of that, our firewall also went down.
Yeah.
She informed me post informing Anil and by the time I had informed Anil, she pinged me that I have already informed Anil. So I was late in communicating to Anil. She communicated it before I did.
Yeah, she's prompt on it. And like I said, you know, I see great changes, you know, and she's like self-driven and whenever she's going for a break or sometimes, you know, her break gets extended by 5 minutes or so, she tells me so, which is good. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yes, and on top she's sincere, right? So whatever you give it to her, she's taking care of it wisely, which is nice.
Yeah, last time when I had a conversation with her, I clearly explained like this is in a scope of improvement and this is where we need to work on because, and I explained the why behind it. So she understood and I asked clearly, are you facing any pressure while working or you think it we are giving you too much because you were doing only action?
Mm.
Vince.
She said, no, I understand this is a mess that I was making and I'll work on that. And that explains the sincerity because most of the engineers, they go, oh, you know, a lot of things has come on the plate. I'm not able to work on it. But she's just opposite of that.
Mm.
The yeah.
Thanks, Shashank. Yeah, no, we really appreciate it and we appreciate everything she's doing, you know, for our team. She has real value to it, so we definitely, you know, happy with how she's progressing. Yeah. Yeah, with that in mind, Shashank, the one thing I just wanted us to probably discuss is just around her
Yeah.
next steps in her growth, right? Because, you know, I know you guys have some trainings and stuff that you all had a schedule with her on. I'm just looking at it, you know, normally July, middle of July to early August is like a good time because, you know, there's less ticket volume and stuff normally from the trends of the last years. So if there is any other trainings that are
plan, Shashank, I would really like if we could plan it between that, you know, sort of second week of July to probably second week of August, which would be good. And Anil, you can come in here to say, you know, the next step of the growth for her, because we've been giving her specific types of tickets, but we want to evolve that and grow that.
Sure.
Yeah.
further now, right, to the next part. So Anil, if you can just highlight some of the other technical parts that you want to expose her to next, then at least Shashank has something to be able to put onto a training schedule for her to support her. So then we can take that next step in her growth of doing more of the different types of system analyst tickets as well.
Sure.
Yep.
Yeah.
Yep, yep. And just to add what Shashank just said, here in F12 in our team, IST Quadra, we want to keep our teammates essential, right? And how they become essential is like adding more skills to their knowledge skill and of course to their resume and overall, right? So
I spoke to Nora already. She needs to appear for the basic AZ 900 certification, right, which is not much. It's not going to be like it's going to create a hole in a pocket. So it is something achievable, and I think we want to see that happening. So.
Here, you know, people have started doing it already. Two of our team members got this certification already. So I think this is a value add, right? When we, not sure if you, if she told you, she has been joining the client meetings as well with us.
Sure.
So we are giving her the chances where she's going to come out of, you know, that comfort zone and then out of that box. And then she'll be more interacting with clients, right? So we'll give her the opportunity. And that's what Roshan always ensures in our team that we give.
Oh, great.
each individual the chance to showcase their skill set to the world. But it comes with a price, right? You need to have those basic skills where you can talk about it. And I think she's into the licensing and then she knows about Microsoft licenses, co-pilot and all.
So that's kind of a new start for our clients where we encouraging our clients to move on to the co-pilot. So I think she's going to be the crucial player in that category, right? So I think with that thought process, I want her to get certification on the licensing.
I.
Yeah.
Yeah, and we have a clear discussion with F12, like if F12 wants any of their engineers to complete the certification, it's a simple that the engineer, like in this case Nora, would complete the certification, she'll share the artifacts, and we'll share the billing with F12, so...
Microsoft licenses and Azure.
Yeah.
She'll get an approval from Rishin first, like this, I want to do this training. Whatever you will suggest, only she will do it. So she'll send an email, Rishin will approve. She will then let us know. We already have a pre-approval process, so that won't be an issue.
She can then complete the training and certification. Once she completes it, she'll share all the documents and we'll share it with the accounting team. They'll bill it to F2 once it comes and then we'll pay her back. So nothing would come on her in that case.
Mm.
Okay.
We have other ISTs who have asked engineers to do it, so I guess Falcon, Fez is in Falcon, correct?
Pheasant Kris.
Yeah, they asked, yeah, they asked their engineer, Cyrus, to do AZ900. He did that. Then in security, we have Ashish and Antrix. They did it. I'm forgetting the CEO's name, he, CTO's name. He asked, he had specifically said like,
Yeah, yeah.
Ohh.
Kaila, yeah.
Yeah, Calvin, because I do not, in fact, that's why. Yeah, so Calvin had approved. So all these things are in place and recently Benjamin and asked Ankur to do the EZ 900 certification. So all these things are coming from after where we are seeing this and this is a very easy process for us as well.
Yeah.
No, yeah, I think the only additional thing, Shashank Agarwal, is just that, you know, from a personal growth point of view, if the if the resource is looking to grow themselves, then this is something from their side as well. They should be proactively, you know, sort of doing and to upskill themselves and keep them updated with the latest technologies that allows them then.
Connect.
to grow further within the organization. So I think that's the important thing as well. We always try to support that and we'll guide where to go from. But there's some part that's employees grow, because this AZ 900, for example, that we do, wherever Nora goes in the future, it's not going to benefit FTR, if you know what I mean. That's our skill set.
Correct.
for her to then fly in the world, you know, as well. So I think that's the other part of it is that that growth is not just for here. It's you take it into your everyday life and anything in the future is going to benefit that, you know, as well. Yeah.
Sure. Point taken. Anything else you would like to add, Rashin or Anil for an Arora?
That's it. I think pretty much we all good so far.
I think, Shashank, if you can just drive just that the part of the training, because I know you all had your own training plan internal, you know, and there was a few things not needed to finish off in terms of training. And then, Anil, if you can just give the feedback in terms of some of these next things that we want to expose it to, so that even if we don't do the official training like in the next month or two for AZ, at least
Okay.
Sure.
Yeah.
Mm.
You know, from ITBD, so they can still guide Nora and have training sessions with her for the few things that you want to expose her to next, because she's doing phishing and all of those things now, but we want to start some of the other troubleshooting and stuff that that is there as well, you know, linked to diagnostics, printers, you know, those type of things and devices and and stuff like that, so...
Yeah, if there's anything else specific, I know I can just shoot that over to Shashank so he can put it into her sort of internal ITBD training plan, and at least you know in the next month we can we can work ourselves, yeah, but on the AZ side, Shashank would like us to sort of after you discuss with Nora as well, for us to commit to like a time range.
you know, within the next three months, for example, and then we work and support her to be able to then achieve that of getting the certification within the three months, you know, as an example, right? Because I want us to commit to that, but this other internal training can continue, you know, ad hoc in between there so that she can still do more and not be waiting on that, is it?
Sure.
Uh, you know, to to before she she does that, yeah, yeah, alright.
Kip.
Sure. And that's definitely a part of the growth. I see definitely that would benefit her. So definitely I'll talk to her regarding this. I just have a connect after 6 minutes with her. So I'll talk to her.
Phelps.
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay, cool. Awesome. No, I think that's it from my side. Thank you so much for your time. As always, thank you for presenting the stuff. We appreciate your support to her as well. You know, if it helps or not. So thanks for that, Sushant.
Thanks, Sushant. Thanks, Anil. Have a great day and great weekend. Thanks, bye.
All right. See ya. Take care, man. You too. Bye-bye. You too. Bye.
OK, you too, just bye.